i i i can add up every dollar i spent on
a woman in my whole life and you know
amount to 10 that'd be probably not a
thousand dollars and you're 31 31 i
don't spend money on women you have
children two oh [ __ ] yeah wait you're 31
and you haven't spent a thousand dollars
in your life on a woman no
you're a real romantic [ __ ]
aren't you i'll tell you hot and spicy
it's two hottest spices in the small
fruit [ __ ]
you said do you like applebee's because
tonight we're going for that two for 20.
and if you're lucky we'll go to the
second half of the menu and it's 30. but
that's only if i like you if you're
really really really wrong i'll take you
to something nice but wait what's
something nice chili's nah i can't come
back get her the bloomin onion a girl a
girl tried to give me to take her to
take her to a real chris but i'm like
[ __ ] you like you even came from for
chris but you want me to take
so i ain't taking but if i could tell
like you
you up you top notch you got your [ __ ]
together i'll take it
what's your deal breaker with a chick so
like if you let's say you start talking
to a girl right yeah let's say she comes
over and some hat like what is it is it
is what's the deal breaker what's the
one thing that'll make you be like ah
nah nah nah i'm good i'm not hitting is
it is it uh bad breath is it uh her feet
ain't done is it i don't like nasty feet
uh feet got to be right but i mean i
think my dear breaker with females is
when you come to my house and get this
and get to singing my songs
oh my god yeah i hate that like come on
bro we're not doing it
like you showing me you're giving me fan
vibes